speaking of the right way what's the
right way to take care of a camera when
you're not using it
uh get a really good ac
um to take care of the camera on the
sets
because the camera's at least in my
worries as a cinematographer when i'm on
set if i shoot a shot like as soon as
they say cut i'm pretty much handing it
off to someone else i won't even want to
look at it i'm
coordinating with the director and
talking about the next scene with the
technical department heads and all that
stuff the camera is the least of my
worries so i assume it's being taken
care of by the great teams that i carry
with me on my cruise
uh the acs and the the
camera interns and all that
as far as owning a camera i think
um just be careful with it you know like
clean it as often as possible try not to
put it in dangerous situations sometimes
you can't avoid it but if you do do it
smart and do it in a way that the camera
is going to be as secure as possible
and i think
you know if you can't afford to break
your camera don't put it in a bad
situation
but if you can
if you can
find yourself you know if it's important
for the scene and you feel like it's pop
if you know if it breaks a lens you're
in there or whatever it's no big deal
like
it's just like anything else like in a
movie you know a prop or a
car crash like sometimes you have to
break something
you know i don't look at a camera as
like the super like
you know
really fragile baby
often
i put the camera in crazy situations
sometimes and that's the only way i can
get the shot but i'm also doing it
confidently knowing that i'm not gonna
do any damage to it
so far i haven't had any accidents
but
i feel like it really contributes to my
style
sometimes i'll put the camera like a
foot off the ground for a car chase you
know
if you're watching michael bay movies
he's breaking cameras all the time
smashing cameras and whatever and
putting the camera in dangerous places
that it can get the shot that he needs
i mean a lot of people hate on michael
bay but that's pretty awesome that he
does that because
when you look at things a different way
like that
you know it opens up the door to a lot
of different possibilities that you can
do if you're super like
you know funny about your things
but again if you are trying to take care
of your camera and you are in a big you
know a way if you are in a situation
where breaking it is a bad thing for you
um you know just keep it in a very
protective case i would say i keep my
camera in a hard
metal box that it locks with like metal
locks
and it has
um memory foam inside of it
super protective i could throw that
thing off of the building and it'd be
fine if i opened it back up
the box might be a little dented but
even the box would probably be fine
so that's the level of care that i put
into my equipment
but
i'm also
you know
riding out in a helicopter with the door
open hanging that thing out the window
every now and then too so it's
a balance there
you